one of the most mysterious characters in
A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones is Varys the master of
whisperers or spy master at King's
Landing also called the spider for his
vast web of informers Varys is a schemer
and a manipulator a master of disguise
an illusion and a keeper of Secrets
whenever anything important happens at
court his lair
watching whispering spinning his secret
webs what's this guy up to who is he
really
and what does he want let's start at the
beginning
Varys was born not in Westeros but in a
city called lys as an orphan boy and
apparently a slave he tells us that he
grew up with a troupe of mamas mamas are
actors or performers but one day in
mirror he was sold to a sort of a
sorcerer who cut off varus's [ __ ] and
bulls and burned them in a magic ritual
Varys was left for dead on the streets
but he managed to survive and become a
great thief when he was driven from
Mirror he went to Pentos and formed a
criminal partnership with a young elder
youma partes Varys trained children to
work for him as thieves like a sort of a
Fagin without balls and came to learn
that secrets are worth more than silver
or sapphires
so Varys as thieves stole information
which eventually made Varys and Illyrio
rich and powerful meanwhile in Westeros
King Aerys Targaryen was going mad
convinced that everyone around him was
plotting against him so when Aerys heard
about varus's talents he brought him to
King's Landing to serve as his spy
master in the following years Varys
Crouch to the Kings side whispering in
his ear like Grima Wormtongue feeding
heiresses paranoia which probably
contributed to heiresses madness and
ultimate downfall in Robert's rebellion
it doesn't seem the Varys intended this
though because he apparently tried to
stop errors from opening his gaze to the
sack of King's Landing but anyway Varys
continued in his role as the master of
whisperers under the new King Robert
Baratheon he learned all the secret
passageways around the red cape he built
up his network of spies mostly mute
children who he calls little birds and
he solidified his power by making people
need him convincing people that is on
their side making sure he's too useful
and
shows too much to be gotten rid of and
eventually the series begins viruses
actions as seen through the eyes of edit
and Tyrion and others of confusing in
book 1 Varys warns Ned that the
Lannisters want to kill Robert he
reports on Daenerys Targaryen to the
small council using Jorah as his spy
though we later find out that Varys
actually protects Dany Varys suggests
the dismissal of Barristan Selmy from
the Kingsguard and he tries to save edad
from execution in clash Varys is helpful
and almost friendly with Tyrion helping
him run the city and protect his
relationship with Shae but in storm he
testifies against Tyrion in his trial
but then he helps save Tyrion from
execution and leads him to kill Tywin
before sending him off to Pentos then
Varys disappears from King's Landing
leaving a coin in the dungeons that
makes Cersei mistrust the Tyrells and
he's gone for all of faced for the end
of Dance he turns up out of nowhere and
murders pycelle and Kevan Lannister
what's he trying to achieve with all
this what's the goal here it's a really
hard to see viruses motivations because
he does everything indirectly and
secretly and softly but it is possible
to piece together his grand plan back in
the very first book we see that Varys is
conspiring with his old friend
Illyrio mopatis who arranges the
marriage between Daenerys Targaryen and
Khal Drogo we're told that the plan at
this point is to use Drogo's Dothraki
army to invade Westeros and crown
Danny's brother viscera as king but
viscera dies then Drago dies and
Daenerys ends up the queen of murine so
in the show the plan now seems to be to
help Daenerys take over Westeros but in
the books it's more complex this boy
called young Griff who Varys and Illyrio
claim is actually Aegon Targaryen the
son of Prince Rhaegar and nephew of
Daenerys widely believed to have been
killed as an infant during Robert's
rebellion Varys and Illyrio say they
secretly rescued Aegon from the war and
have been raising him ever since to be a
perfect King for Westeros which raises
the question of what they were planning
to do with Visser's
viscera sand Aegon can't both be king
one likely explanation is that Varys and
Illyrio lied and never actually intended
for visitors to be King and why would
they he's crazy and cruel and would
obviously make a
ruler Aegon on the other hand seems a
pretty decent kid and has a better claim
to the throne and has been shaped for
rule since before he could walk by
Illyrio and Varys as people they clearly
want Aegon not viscera on the throne so
why do they try to give viscera Siddarth
rocky army why tell him to invade
Westeros the plan seems to have been to
use viscera psa's Dothraki invasion of
Westeros as a way of destabilizing and
distracting Westeros making it easier
for Aegon to turn up later and take over
compared to crazy viscera sand his
savage foreign army Aegon would look
like the good guy
a savior come from across the sea to
bind up the wounds of bleeding Westeros
of course after viscera stays the plan
changes for a while they try to get
Aegon and Daenerys together to marry
them and join their forces and invade
Westeros together but that doesn't work
out and Aegon ends up invading Westeros
without her landing in the Stormlands
with an army called the golden company
in dance so the plan has changed a lot
throughout the series but the overall
goal seems to have remained the same to
make Aegon Targaryen the king of
Westeros this really helps to understand
varus's actions throughout the series
early on he's trying to delay any
conflict in Westeros until viscera is
ready to invade so he tries to protect
Robert and Ned from the Lannisters and
he maintains an appearance of loyalty by
informing on Narus while on the down-low
he's supporting her not only by
protecting her from assassination but by
sending useful people to her like Sir
Barry and later Tyrion by the end of
storm Varys changes his strategy trying
to destabilize and weaken the Lannister
regime in preparation for Aegon's
invasion so he leads Tyrion to kill
Tywin he drives a pot Cersei in the
Tyrells and he kills Kevan Lannister the
last person at this point is really
holding the realm together all
throughout the series Varys is working
to pave the way for Aegon's invasion but
why Varys endlessly says that he serves
the realm that he's a loyal servant of
the realm and the realm needs peace if
that's true why does he create conflict
and chaos and try to start a war to
install Aegon as king if Varys wants a
good Targaryen King he should have just
supported Prince Rhaegar all those years
ago
Rhaegar sounds like he would have been a
great ruler and since he was Aerys
rightful heir there would have been no
war required to make him King
but varus actively worked against
Rhaegar by warning the Mad King against
him possibly even urging arrow so
disinherit him so that crazy kid visits
would have taken the throne instead if
Faris really wants a good King in a
peaceful realm why did he undermine
Rhaegar and later under King Robert the
realm enters a period of peace and
prosperity the world of Ice and Fire
calls it a golden era admittedly there
is that massive debt probably cos of
Littlefinger but still the realms doing
pretty well so why does Varys spend this
time plotting to ruin the peace start a
war and install a new king after Robert
dies things do get bad in the war of the
five kings which again is mostly
Littlefinger's fault but the war does
end and the realm starts getting back
into pretty good shape under Tommen
Varys says himself that Kevan Lannister
does a good job of starting to make
peace and unite the Seven Kingdoms under
Tommen's rule but instead of supporting
what could have become a peaceful stable
regime Varys again undermines the peace
by killing heaven creating conflict and
continuing the plot of Aegon's invasion
that's three potentially peaceful and
prosperous regimes that Varys is
actively undermined if Varys really just
wants a peaceful realm why does he keep
doing this what possible reason could he
have to support this kid Aegon above all
others véra suggests that Aegon would be
a great king he says he's been trained
educated instilled with good values
shaped for rule since before he could
walk but isn't it extremely naive to
believe that training can guarantee that
someone will be a great king aegon's
just a teenager with little experience
of the real world he's barely even been
to the realm he intends to rule even if
Aegon does turn out to be a great king
what's stopping his heir or successor
from being just as bad as Matt Aerys
within just a generation varus's grand
plan could easily leave Westeros in a
worse position than it was in the first
place and that's if the plan even works
if Aegon is defeated thousands would
lose their lives for nothing and the
original plan sending viscera sin first
is even more risky loosing thousands of
Dorothy's averages on Westeros would be
terribly destructive and cause lots of
long-term
and what a viscera actually succeeded in
taking over Westeros he could do all
sorts of damage and it's not like he'd
happily hand over the crown when Aegon
showed up varus's supposed plan for
peace involves an awful lot of war and
destruction and risk and he's actively
sabotage several other much safer
opportunities for a peaceful realm to
pursue it it seems obvious that Varys
and Illyrio's true goal isn't just a
peaceful realm but a realm ruled by he
gan but why why does a eunuch for mere
and a merchant from Pentos men with no
apparent connections to Westeros all the
Targaryen 'he's worked so hard to put
Aegon Targaryen on the Iron Throne
tyrion asks this a Valyria wind dance
and Illyrio says he hopes to make money
out of it but tyrion thinks he's a liar
that there's something in this venture
worth more to him than coin or castles
and Illyrio admits that even fat old
fools like him have friends and debts of
affection to repay who are these friends
what are these debts of affection could
they explain the real reasons why Varys
and Illyrio won't pay gone on the throne
the answers may lie in a theory called
the Blackfyre theory to cover some
history real quick about a hundred and
twenty years ago the king of Westeros
was Aegon the fourth Targaryen called
the unworthy because he was one of the
worst kings the realm had ever had he
was corrupt and cruel full of greed and
lust he fathered dozens of bastards
including Brynden rivers or Bloodraven
now known as the three-eyed crow and
shiera seastar who may be related to
Quaithe and aegor rivers called
bittersteel and daemon rivers who took
the name black fire and a black dragon
as his heraldry on king egg on the death
bed he legitimized all his bastards
which put them in line to the throne
Aegon Strube on Sunday Ron still should
have been the rightful heir but that was
disputed by daemon who called himself
King and fought a war against Aron for
the throne daemon was killed in this
first Blackfyre rebellion but
bittersteel who supported him fled
Westeros founded a mercenary company
called the golden company and swore to
put a black fire on the Iron Throne over
the next 50 years there were five more
Blackfyre rebellion
some led by bittersteel and his golden
company until
finally in the fifth Blackfyre rebellion
a young sir Barristan Selmy killed
maelys the monstrous the last black fire
or at least we're told that malice is
the last black fire but he was
apparently only the last of the male
line of house Blackfyre which might
imply that the female line is still
alive many fans believe that Aegon is a
descendant of that female line that is
not really a Targaryen at all but a
black fire and there's strong evidence
supporting this idea were repeatedly
warned in visions and prophecies of a
false dragon or the mummer's dragon
mummer's dragon is a cloth dragon on
poles used in performances and of course
Varys is closely linked to mamma's he
was raised by them taught by them and
constantly uses their skills of acting
an illusion so the idea here is that
Aegon is the mummer's dragon the false
black dragon who Varys presents as a
Targaryen even though he's actually a
black fire which fits perfectly with
varus's talk of power and belief and
perception
he says the power resides where men
believe it resides and men believe that
power resides in Targaryen blood no
matter if the boy is actually a black
fire another little symbolic hint is a
story we're told about a black Iron
Dragon that was used as the sign for an
inn until someone broke it and threw it
away because it looked like the black
fire dragon but many years later part of
it washed up and the black iron had gone
red with rust this alludes to the story
of Aegon the black dragon house
Blackfyre was seemingly destroyed years
ago but a survivor has now emerged
disguised as a red dragon a Targaryen
but probably the strongest evidence for
the black via theory concerns the golden
company the army that joins Aegon in his
invasion of Westeros in Dance
it is super [ __ ] weird for the golden
company to fight for Aegon Targaryen
because the golden company was founded
by bitter steel to fight against the
Targaryens for the black fires they
fought in the Blackfyre rebellion 'z
they were led by black fires they are a
brotherhood of X Isles united by the
dream of bitter steel and the dream of
bitter steel was to defeat the Targaryen
and put a black fire on the
thrown so why would the golden company
fight for Aegon Targaryen Tyrion
questions Illyrio about this an Illyrio
brushes away the objection as if it were
a fly saying a Blackfyre tug area and
tomato tomahto all the company really
wants is to go home to Westeros which is
like maybe but that seems to contradict
Illyrio's earlier claim that the golden
company fights for Aegon because of a
contract rich in blood which sounds like
it refers to the golden company's
history with the blackfyres so there is
a lot of uncertainty and secrecy here
but given what we know about the golden
company and given all these hints about
blackfyres and the mummer's dragon it
seems likely that the golden company
fights for Aegon Targaryen because they
know he's secretly a Blackfyre some
versions of the theory go further
suggesting that Aegon might not only be
a Blackfyre but that he might be
Illyrio's son Illyria clearly has
affection affair gone he's really sad
that he doesn't get to spend time with
him he praises him gives him little
gifts of his favorite food who even has
a chest of children's clothes in his
home that may have been a Gon's when he
was younger maybe Illyrio treats Aegon
like this because Aegon is his son
Aegon's Blackfyre blood would come from
Illyrio's now dead wife Sara who had
pale golden hair streaked by silver just
like a black fire and a name that sounds
like a Targaryen or black via named Sara
maybe this black fire survivor through
the female lion and the mother of Aegon
black fire with Illyria the evidence for
this idea isn't very strong but it would
go a long way in explaining why Illyrio
wants Aegon to be king Illyrio deeply
loved Sara
he sacrificed a lot of political power
and status to be with her and after she
dies of greyscale he keeps her petrified
stony hands as a keepsake which is quite
creepy but it's also a clear expression
of passionate love
maybe Sara wanted for her son Aegon what
all her Blackfyre ancestors had failed
to claim the Iron Throne of Westeros it
might even have been a promise me Ned
sort of a situation maybe as Sara was
slowly dying of greyscale she got her
husband Illyrio to swear to honor her
memory by granting her son he's
perceived birthright
the throne this also could give Varys a
pretty good reason to support Aegon
Blackfyre Varys is a close friend of two
Illyrio and may also have been close
with Sara so it makes sense that he
might want to help support Aegon some
people even suggest that Varys and Sara
might be related brother and sister
perhaps after all they both happen to
come from lys they both happen to end up
with Illyrio in Pentos and maybe Varys
shaves his head to hide the pale blonde
hair that he may share with Sara there's
a hint for this in that another
character who shaves his head bald is
egg in Duncan egg egg shaves his head to
hide his Valyrian blond hair and when
Varys is introduced in the first book he
is plump perfumed powdered and as
hairless as an egg also having Blackfyre
blood might explain why Varys was
castrated in a magic fire ritual we know
that fire magic in this series sometimes
requires king's blood and if Varys is a
descendant of the Targaryen Xand
blackfyres he has Kings blood maybe
that's why he was bought by the sorcerer
in the first place one more little thing
is that we're told that only the blood
of the dragon would ever know the
secrets of the red cape specifically its
secret passageways and as it happens
Varys knows those secrets very well so
it's possible that Varys is Sarah's
Blackfyre brother but even if he's not
even if he's only a close friend of
Sarah and Illyrio those connections
could help make Varys and Illyrio's
grand plan make a whole lot more sense
because the story were told that Varys
serves the realm and just wants peace
doesn't make sense
Varys has actively undermined three
potentially peaceful regimes he's taken
huge dangerous risks orchestrated whole
Wars all to crown a teenager who might
not actually make a good King could this
really be the ultimate goal of this
master player of the game of Thrones all
this stuff about debts of affection and
the black fires and familial connections
hints that there might be a deeper layer
to Varys as a character because all this
time Varys has seemed to be so
dispassionate so cold and calculating
people see him as creepy almost inhuman
not as a man but as a sinister
all-seeing spider and a eunuch beside
Circe says that the reason why Varys is
so dangerous is because he doesn't have
a [ __ ] implying that he lacks the
passions and desires and weaknesses that
motivate other people and Varys plays
this up saying ah no one loves a eunuch
they sing no songs for spiders and in
the show it's suggested quite clearly
that he has no desire which leaves him
free to work towards higher rational
goals like a peaceful realm but maybe
there's more to varus than this cold
rational exterior after all he grew up
with actors he's a master of disguise he
talks endlessly about the power of
illusion and he says pretty explicitly
that his role as a sly unscrupulous spy
is an act maybe behind the act behind
the illusions behind the curtain is a
man just a man with human passions
someone who works out of love for his
friends and family George Martin says
the only thing worth writing about is
the human heart in conflict with itself
a cold rational scheming spider who
manipulates politics and orchestrated
Wars for purely cold rational reasons is
not the human heart in conflict with
itself a much better story is that of a
man who was born alone into the world
who was betrayed at a young age who was
cut and beaten and suffered and so
learned to cherish the family he had a
man who used illusion and deception to
play the part of a passionless eunuch
who only serves the realm all the while
secretly working over years and years
out of love for his family
Illyria Sara and aegon maybe this could
be revealed in a climactic dramatic
scene where varus's plans come crashing
down perhaps even the scene of varus's
death imagine a sudden tragic
bittersweet realization that this evil
scheming spider who stole and lied and
started wars and killed good men who
turned the whole damn realm into his
puppet show did what he did out of love
either that or he's a merman thanks for
watching this video was drawn from the
ideas of the Song of Ice and Fire fan
community there are links in the
description to relevant essays and posts
the series by Brendon B fish on egg on
was especially influential here thanks
also to all the patrons supporting this
channel on patreon if you'd like to
support this channel please pledge at
patreon.com slash
old shift x Cheers